la tunisie célèbre aujourd'hui le 11ème
anniversaire de la révolution de 2011 et
ce à la recrudescence des cas covin le
gouvernement a annoncé que toute
manifestation rassemblement était
interdite et compris les célébrations de
ce 14 janvier mais pour l'opposition
cette décision politique n'a pas lieu
d'être ils ont donc maintenu leur appel
à manifester au point tout de suite
depuis tunis avec notre correspondant
bas samedi
un anniversaire au goût amer pour les
tunisiens qui célèbre aujourd'hui le
11ème anniversaire de la révolution
tunisienne c'était le 14 janvier 2011
zine el abidine ben ali a quitté le pays
subitement sous la pression populaire
récemment le président kai eide avait
décidé de modifier cette date
anniversaire non plus le 14 janvier date
à laquelle le président va quitter le
territoire mais le 17 décembre date à
laquelle un vendeur ambulant du sud de
la tunisie à sidi bouzid s'était immolé
par le feu causant le début des
mouvements de protestation à travers
tout pays qui ont conduit au départ de
zine el abidine ben ali pour des causes
de kovy c'est la deuxième année que les
autorités interdisent tout rassemblement
toute manifestation alors que les
autorités et le gouvernement ont annoncé
l'argument sanitaire et sécuritaire
l'opposition elle part d'une décision
politique une volonté du président de la
république de museler la parole de
l'opposition la société civile et partis
politiques ont décidé de maintenir coûte
que coûte ces manifestations malgré
l'interdiction de manifester et de se
rassembler que ce soit le parti ennahdha
les démocrates voient encore certains
membres de la société civile tous ont
décidé de se rassembler aujourd'hui sur
cette mythique avenue habib bourguiba
pour célébrer cet anniversaire et pour
demander au président de la république
la fin des mesures exceptionnelles le
retour à la démocratie pour le moment
une grande présence policière sur cette
avenue habib bourguiba avec des points
de filtrage à travers toutes les paires
pendulaires qui mène à cette avenue
habib bourguiba pas de manifestants pour
le moment la circulation elle n'a pas
été coupé ni aux piétons ni aux
automobilistes mais pour le moment
aucune banderole aucun mouvement de
protestation aucune manifestation n'est
à déclarer ici au coeur de la capitale
tunisienne